Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 264. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich werde heute aber nicht so heißen und ich bin so alt, dass ich eigentlich keinen Bock mehr auf diese Sendung habe. Und warum, das erklären wir euch heute ganz ausführlich. Es geht nämlich um das Aufweichen von Verschlüsselung. So, ich bin heute Monoxid, weil das mein Twitter-Handle ist und weil wir sonst in der Sendung wahrscheinlich Probleme kriegen. Denn bei mir zu Gast ist Markus. Hallo, Markus. Also Markus Drenger, um genauer zu sein. Jemand, der auch im CCC ist, der sich sehr viel für netzpolitische Themen interessiert und auch dazu arbeitet. Also nicht im Sinne von Erwerbsarbeit, sondern im Sinne von Aktivismus. Außerdem zu Gast, Anne Roth. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Netzreferentin, nee, was? Referente für Netzpolitik der Bundestagsfraktion Die Linke. So was ist richtig, oder? Und wir sprechen außerdem mit Julia Reda, ex-Europaparlament-Abgeordnete, jetzt bei der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, die Leiterin des Projekts Control, Urheberrecht und Kommunikationsfreiheit. Die kommt aber später dazu, aber wird auf jeden Fall heute dabei sein. Warum sind diese Menschen heute hier? Und warum sprechen wir über die Aufweichung von Verschlüsselung? Na ja, es hat sich also zugetragen, dass und das Geräusch im Hintergrund, die nahende Sirene, passt genau dazu, dass der Ministerrat der EU ein Schreiben ausgegeben hat. Und da steht, und da wird es schon spannend, da steht nicht direkt drin, lass uns mal bitte die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung bei den Messengern aufweichen, sondern da steht, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, in den Gesprächen, die ich jetzt darüber geführt habe, da steht was ganz Schwammiges drin, dass man aber eigentlich, wenn man Ahnung vom Thema hat, nur lesen kann als, lass uns doch mal die Verschlüsselung, die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung bei den Messengern aufweichen. Bevor ich jetzt meine Gäste zu Wort kommen lasse, möchte ich zwei Dinge tun. Einmal um Entschuldigung bitten. Das Thema Aufweichung von Verschlüsselung ist mega alt und die Kämpfe dagegen sind mega oft geführt worden und ich versuche das in diesen Sendungen immer zu vermeiden, aber vielleicht passieren heute Referenzen auf Dinge oder ihr verspürt so ein gewisses Abgegessenheitsgefühl, wie wenn man einem Kind zum tausendstmal sagt so nein, nicht das Ding essen, was auf dem Fußboden lag, das ist nicht so gut. So und das andere ist Ende-zu-Ende-Verschüsselung, ganz ganz kurz am Anfang sozusagen erklärt, was das bedeutet. Ende-zu-Ende-Verschüsselung ist etwas, das ihr übers Internet schickt, kann nur der lesen, an den ihr es schickt, sonst niemand. Bei Messengern heißt das also, ihr habt einen Messenger, jemand, den ihr kennt, hat einen Messenger, dem schickt er eine Nachricht und niemand sonst weiß, was da drin steht. Niemand, nicht mal der Betreiber des Messengers. Das ist der ganz ganz ganz wichtige Punkt. Und warum das wichtig ist und wie man das kaputt machen kann, das besprechen wir heute. So, ich weiß gar nicht, mit wem ich jetzt anfangen soll. Ich stelle euch mal die Frage, dann könnt ihr euch ausruhen, wer antwortet, was genau war das denn eigentlich für ein Papier? Also was genau steht drin? Ich hab ja so ein bisschen drum rum geschwafelt jetzt, aber was für ein Papier fordert da eigentlich genau was?
Das war ein Papier vom Ministerrat der Europäischen Union, in dem die Mitgliedstaaten, also die Regierungen der Mitgliedstaaten, die EU-Kommissionen aufgefordert haben, einen Vorschlag zu machen, wie man mit dem Thema Verschlüsselung umgehen sollte, um dann gewisse Inhalte scannen oder filtern zu können. Das heißt, die Kommission hat jetzt den Auftrag, dort einen Regulierungsvorschlag zu machen, und die muss quasi jetzt einen Verordnungstext schreiben, den man sich später angucken kann, wo sie sich jetzt sozusagen positionieren sollen, mit welchen technischen Maßnahmen sie Verschlüsselung umgehen oder aufweichen möchten.
Also noch hat sie den Auftrag nicht, denn vorläufig ist das noch im Entwurfsstadium dieses Papier. Das heißt, es hat einen Vorschlag gegeben und darüber diskutieren die jetzt gerade noch. Und es gibt auch verschiedene neue Versionen davon. Und erst wenn das abgestimmt wird und es sieht so aus, und das stand ja auch in dem Artikel von Erich Möchel auf der Webseite von ORF, wo dieses Papier geleakt wurde, ist der Plan, das Anfang Dezember zu verabschieden. Aber im Moment, und das kann man auch sehen, wenn man auf den EU-Webseiten rumsurft, gibt es sozusagen verschiedene neue Versionen davon, wo die im Moment sich noch ein bisschen verhackeln, was da endgültig drinstehen soll. Und wenn das dann verabschiedet ist, dann fordern sie auf.
Warte mal, also ich habe ja mal geglaubt, es ist kompliziert, Ende zu Endeverschönung zu erklären. Sondern was Kompliziertes ist zu erklären, habe ich es richtig verstanden? Das ist der Entwurf zu einem Papier, der wenn er verabschiedet würde, die Kommission beauftragen würde, sich Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie man etwas machen könnte?
Wollen wir heute ein EU-Chaosradio machen?
Nein, nein, nein, ich will nur hören, ob ich das richtig verstanden habe. Dann ist die nächste Frage, die man stellen muss. Wenn da aber nur drin steht, dass sich jemand mal Gedanken machen soll über so ein Thema, warum geht dann alle davon aus, dass das bedeutet, dass man Ende-zu-Ende-Faschistellungen dafür kaputt machen muss?
Es gibt da ein entsprechendes Papier dazu, in dem technische Lösungen zur Erkennung von Kinderpornografie in Ende-zu-Ende-Kommunikationen vorgeschlagen werden. Da gibt es drei Vorschläge aus der Kommission. Das eine ist traditionelle Hintertüren, also Lücken in Software zu finden, die auszunutzen, um dann mit Trojanern oder Ähnliches an Inhalte zu kommen. Die zweite Möglichkeit wäre, die Provider, also Messengerdienste zu verpflichten, kleinzeitig nach Inhalten zu scannen, bevor man eine Nachricht abschicken kann, dass z.B. die Anhänge gescannt werden und gewisse Hasht-Werte mit dem Ministert abgeglichen werden. Die dritte Möglichkeit wäre, sichere Enklaven oder homomorphe Verschlüsselung, also Verschlüsselungsverfahren, in denen man trotz Verschlüsselung prüfen kann, ob da gewisse verbotene Inhalte drin sind.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt, weil ich dachte, die Begründung wäre Terrorismus und nicht der Darstellung von Kindesmissbrauch.
Je nachdem, wie es gerade passt.
Es gibt mehrere Verfahren, in denen das gleiche Thema gewirkt wird.
Also wir kommen da noch hin. Aber erst mal bitte dieses eine Papier, dass der Anlass für die eine Aufregung ist. Das heißt, da selber steht nichts drin, aus dem man das schließen kann, sondern das kann man nur aus dem Kontext schließen?
Ja, das kann man aus dem Kontext schließen. Das erste war die Antwort auf Terroranschläge und auf die Anschläge in Frankreich und in Wien und was man da jetzt noch machen kann. Dazu kam natürlich auch das Thema Messenger-Verschlüsselung etc. Und in diesem Rahmen gab es Vorschläge und den Wunsch, dass man dort das Thema wieder aufgreift von Seiten der Kommission, um dann eine Regelung zu finden, wie man diese Going Dark Debatte mit neuen Regelungen bewirft.
Was ist die Going Dark Debatte?
Going Dark ist immer das Stichwort, dass Sicherheitsbehörden sagen, dass sie immer weniger sehen und immer weniger beobachten können, weil immer mehr digitale Kommunikation verschlüsselt wird. Und deswegen geht bei denen das Licht aus, weil sie nicht mehr sehen können, was wie gesprochen und getextet wird.
Und sozusagen bei mir ist es jetzt zum Beispiel so, dass ich gerade dachte, ich hab das Papier natürlich gelesen, aber ich müsste im Moment, wenn du mir jetzt fragst, was steht da genau drin, müsste ich nochmal gucken, was damit zu tun hat, dass es unendlich viele solche Papiere gibt, die im Grunde immer wieder um diese Geschichte kreiseln. Das ist verschiedene, ich würde sagen Vorwände, Strafverfolgungsbehörden, Geheimdienste würden sagen, Anlässe gibt, die genau diese Going Dark Debatte immer weiter am Leben halten. Ich hab zum Beispiel mal geschaut, dieses Papier hat ja den wirklich gloriosen Titel Security Through Encryption and Security Despite Encryption. Also Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung. So heißt es, steht oben drüber. Genau diese Phrase, die da jetzt oben drüber steht, die ist überhaupt nicht neu. Die findet sich zum Beispiel in einer Antwort auf eine schriftliche Frage von Konstantin von Notz aus dem Jahr 2015, wo der gefragt hat, da geht es um bestimmte Dinge, die IT-Sicherheit, Verschlüsselung und so weiter, fragt Konstantin von Notz fünf Jahre her. Und genau in dieser Antwort kommt dann der Satz vor, die Bundesregierung setzt sich dafür ein, dass zum einen starke und sichere Verschlüsselung verfügbar ist und zum anderen unsere Sicherheitsbehörden ertüchtigt werden, damit umzugehen. Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung. Das ist sozusagen der Grundsatz, den die vor sich her tragen. Diese Argumentation, die steht in unendlich vielen solchen Papieren, Resolutionen, Vorschlägen und letztlich dann auch Gesetz entwirfen. Das ist gewissermaßen so, dass das Mantra der Bundesregierung und eben auch in der EU oder soll dann jetzt weiter wieder fortgeschrieben werden, dass die schon verstanden haben, dass es diese Debatte gibt, die einfach sehr unterschiedliche starke Seiten hat. Es gibt ja auch gute Gründe, warum wir weiterhin eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung haben, warum das nicht zwischendurch mal verboten worden ist beispielsweise, weil es einfach wahnsinnig viele Leute gibt, die sagen, wir brauchen eine stabile Verschlüsselung. Das sind Hacker natürlich, das sind GrundrechtsaktivistInnen, aber das ist auch die Wirtschaft beispielsweise. Und das ist bei der Bundesregierung angekommen, deswegen steht immer überall vorne noch mal ein langer Absatz dazu. Ja, wir haben auch verstanden, für die IT-Sicherheit und für die Grundrechte ist das ganz wichtig. Und trotzdem wollen wir aber bei den Terroristen mitlesen, weil das ist gefährlich, was die machen. Oder wahlweise Kinderpornografie oder wahlweise verschiedene andere Dinge, die immer sozusagen abwechselnd als Anlass hochgeholt werden, um zu sagen so, aber wir müssen diese verschlüsselten Inhalte mitlesen können. Und dieses Papier, diese Resolution, ich will nicht sagen, man braucht sich nicht aufregen. Ganz im Gegenteil, man muss sich aufregen. Man muss jetzt gerade total genau hingucken, weil das im Moment aus verschiedenen Richtungen kommt. Es gibt im Moment eine Debatte um neue Gesetzgebungen.
Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp. Also ja, das Problem ist dringend und wir kommen noch dazu. Aber ich würde gerne sagen, ich würde jetzt erst mal bei diesem Ding bleiben, weil wir auch sozusagen die technische Seite, also nicht in der Tiefe darstellen wollen, aber trotzdem mal drüber reden wollen. Und du hast ja gerade schon gesagt, also die Idee sozusagen, die uns präsentiert wird, ist sichere Verschüstung, voll das geile Ding, gut für die Wirtschaft, brauchen wir, aber wir müssten auch mitlesen können. Ich versuche noch mal die einfachen Fragen zu stellen, ich muss nachher noch mal losfahren, aber jetzt nicht. Also dann frage ich sozusagen in der Rolle des Unbedarften, der diese Meldung hört und das finde ich superdefinitiv, warum geht das denn nicht? Also ich meine, das klingt doch total logisch. Ich meine, ich kann doch auch sichere Autos bauen und trotzdem im Zweifel, wenn im Sommer der Hund eingeschlossen ist, den herausholen. Wo ist denn bitte das Problem? Kann mir mal bitte jemand den technischen Grund dafür erklären, warum man Ende-zu-Ende-Verschüsselungen nicht aufmachen kann, um die bösen Terroristen zu fangen? Das muss doch gehen irgendwie.
Das geht schon, aber wenn man das kann, wenn das technisch möglich ist, dann können halt auch die bösen Terroristen oder irgendwelche anderen Leute oder andere Geheimdienste oder, oder, oder auf demselben Weg gegebenenfalls auch mitlesen. Und dann ist es halt keine sichere Verschlüsselung mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das so einfach schlucken kann. Marcus, was hältst du denn davon?
Ich glaube, er kann uns nicht hören. Er gibt gerade...
So, ich glaube, da wird ein Reboot gemacht. Ich glaube auch, dass Julia Reda gleich dazu kommt. Aber solange müssten wir uns noch mal mit der Frage weiter beschäftigen. Also du sagst, das geht nicht, weil es kaputt ist. Das könnte man technisch jetzt natürlich noch ein bisschen auseinandernehmen. Aber dahinter steckt ja der Glaube, dass es sozusagen keine vertrauenswürdige Möglichkeit gibt, Verschlüsselungen lesbar zu machen. Oder verstehe ich das falsch?
Na, es ist immer die Frage, wer wem vertraut. Also die Sicherheitsbehörden und die Bundesregierung und die EU und die Geheimdienste und Europol und ich weiß nicht wer, die sagen natürlich, sie sind total vertrauenswürdig. Und sie machen das nur aus total nachvollziehbaren Zwecken und nur um Verbrecher zu fangen und so weiter. Und deswegen ist das total okay, wenn sie das machen. Und nun leben wir aber ja im Rechtsstaat und haben bestimmte Grundrechte, die da heißen, es darf nicht einfach jeder irgendwas mitlesen aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Und genau diese Frage, was ist da der verhältnismäßig und der notwendige Grund, die ist ja ein permanenter Prozess von Verhandlungen. Das ist ja keine matte Aufgabe, wo immer dasselbe Ergebnis dabei rauskommt, sondern es gibt einfach unterschiedliche Ansichten, was da ein sinnvoller Grund ist und was nicht. Das ist das eine Problem.
Aber ich würde gerne Julia Reda begrüßen. Hallo und guten Abend. Nur zu deiner Information. Vielen Dank, dass du auch dabei bist. Wir haben dich schon ausführlich vorgestellt, dass du noch nicht da warst, um möglichst viel deiner Zeit in Anspruch nehmen zu können. Wir haben schon besprochen, was der Anlass für die aktuelle Diskussion ist, nämlich das eine Papier, das Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung nahelegt, sich mal damit zu beschäftigen, wie man die aufmachen kann. Das andere, was argumentiert, ist der Missbrauch von Kindern. Die muss man ja auch verhindern, indem man Dinge anders macht. Wir waren jetzt erst mal bei der Frage gelandet, hinter dem Aufriss, der dagegen gemacht wird, scheint der Gedanke zu stecken. Ich stelle diese Frage aus der Perspektive dessen, der keine Ahnung hat, sondern das hört. Es scheint technisch also gar nicht möglich zu sein, Versicherung sicher zu gestalten und trotzdem mitlösen zu können. Aber warum nicht?
Naja, ich denke, das Problem ist, dass in dem Moment, wo irgendein Dritter auf die Inhalte der Kommunikation zugreifen kann, also egal, ob es jetzt der Anbieter der Messenger-App ist oder eben eine Behörde, in dem Moment ist es keine echte Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung mehr, weil Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung eben auf dem Prinzip beruht, dass selbst der Anbieter des Dienstes die Inhalte der Kommunikation nicht mitlesen kann.
Aber, das ist ja beim Telefonen, da will ich ja auch, wenn ich telefoniere, sozusagen nur mit dem anderen sprechen, aber dann kann ja die Behörde sich ab und zu da reinhängen, wenn ein Richter beschließt, dass jetzt eine Telekommunikationsüberwachung an den Start gebracht werden darf. Warum kann man das nicht machen, bei technischer Verschlüsselung von digitalen Diensten?
Na ja, also ich glaube, man muss zwischen der rechtlichen Ebene und der technischen Ebene unterscheiden. Also es gibt natürlich auch viele unverschlüsselte Kommunikationswege über das Internet. Und die Frage, ob dann Sicherheitsbehörden den Inhalt dieser Informationen abfragen dürfen oder nicht, das ist eine rechtliche Frage. Aber in der aktuellen Diskussion geht es ja darum, ob diese Anbieter von Messengerdiensten, wie zum Beispiel WhatsApp oder Signal, überhaupt solche Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungen anbieten dürfen, ohne dass dort hinter Türen eingebaut werden. Und in dem Moment, wo man eben das Angebot eines solchen Dienstes einer sicheren Kommunikation verbietet oder verhindert, schadet das nicht nur den Menschen, die vielleicht ihre Privatsphäre wahren wollen, sondern es ist auch ein großes IT-Sicherheitsproblem. Also auch das ist, glaube ich, ein Aspekt, der in der Diskussion ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen ist bisher.
Also ich frage mich tatsächlich, kann man das, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das sagen soll, als naturwissenschaftliche Wahrheit annehmen, dass, wenn ein Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungssystem eine Hintertür hat, ist es eben keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung mehr oder ist das auch in der Diskussion?
Also die EU-Kommission hat selber, als sie über dieses Problem Kindesmissbrauch ein Strategiepapier entwickelt hat, verschiedene Szenarien durchgespielt. Also wie diese beiden gegensätzlichen Ziele miteinander in Einklang gebracht werden können. Einerseits eben die Verschlüsselung und andererseits, dass trotzdem in irgendeiner Form Kindesmissbrauch, der über diese Kommunikationskanäle stattfindet, erkannt werden soll. Und letzten Endes alle diese Vorschläge, also es gab da zehn verschiedene Vorschläge, die diskutiert wurden, basieren in irgendeiner Form darauf, dass es jedenfalls keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung ist. Also teilweise funktionieren diese Vorschläge schon so, dass die eigentliche Übertragung des Inhalts der Nachrichten verschlüsselt ist, aber dass zum Beispiel, wenn der Inhalt noch auf dem Handy der einen Person ist, mit einer Datenbank abgeglichen werden muss. Also zum Beispiel, dass da ein Hasch abgeglichen wird.
So, jetzt ist zum Zeitmal das Wort Hasch gefallen, jetzt müsst ihr es kurz erklären.
Ja, im Prinzip, wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen, es geht um dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch, dann wird eben nicht das Bild, um das es geht, auf das Handy geschickt und verglichen, ob das dasselbe ist wie das, was sich in dieser App befindet, sondern stattdessen ein Hash-Wert, der quasi mathematisch dieses Bild darstellt. Ja, also ich glaube, um es kurz zu fassen, es ist dann halt keine echte Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung mehr, weil eben der Inhalt der Kommunikation analysiert wird und darüber Aussagen getroffen werden können.
Ich glaube, das ist im Grunde eigentlich auch relativ leicht runterzubrechen. Also Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung bedeutet ja, wenn ich mit dir kommuniziere, wenn ich das eine ende und du bist das andere Ende und ich kann den Inhalt lesen und du kannst den Inhalt lesen und dazwischen kann den niemand lesen, dazwischen wird verschlüsselt.
Punkt.
Und alles, was da mitliest, bedeutet, es ist nicht mehr Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung in dem Sinn, wie wir das verstehen.
Also entschuldigt, dass ich dann sozusagen einen Vergleich ziehe, der möglicherweise sozusagen ein bisschen platt ist, aber ich muss es trotzdem fragen. Das Prinzip, dass nur Sender und Empfänger den Inhalt kennen, gilt ja im Prinzip für die Post auch. Also für die normale Briefpost. Aber da gibt es Möglichkeiten, da reinzugucken. In Ausnahmefällen und so weiter und so fort. Dann kann man sich natürlich, wie gesagt, von außen die Situation betrachtet, fragen, Moment mal, ihr macht bei digitaler Verschlüsselung so einen riesen Aufstand, aber bei den Briefen nicht. Woran liegt das? Liegt es daran, dass das Kind da eh in den Brunnen gefallen ist und das schaffen wir sowieso nicht mehr? Oder gibt es da noch einen qualitativen Unterschied in einen Briefumschlag aufmachen und digitale Verschlüsselung aufmachen?
Also der Brief selber ist ja nicht verschlüsselt. Ich meine, der steckt in einem Umschlag, aber Papier ist jetzt sicherlich keine Technologie, die irgendwie von der Sicherheit her mit kryptographischen Verfahren gleichzusetzen wäre. Ich glaube, man muss da wirklich nochmal unterscheiden zwischen dem, was ist rechtlich erlaubt, darf die Behörde diese Kommunikation mitlesen oder nicht. Und die andere Frage ist, kann sie es? Und kann sie eben den Menschen vorschreiben, auf bestimmte technische Verfahren, in dem Fall Verschlüsselung, zu verzichten? Und ich denke, das ist der problematische Punkt an der Stelle, dass es hier bei diesem Vorschlag darum geht, also dass versucht wird, zu verhindern, dass Leute Zugang zu sicherer Verschlüsselungstechnologie haben. Und vielleicht, um es noch ein bisschen plastischer zu machen, wenn ich einem Brief verschicke, wo irgendwelche privaten Informationen über mich drin stehen, dann ist auch die Gefahr, dass irgendwelche kriminellen Dritten diesen Brief in die Hände bekommen, vergleichsweise gering. Und man kann vielleicht auch besser nachvollziehen, wenn der Brief schon mal aufgemacht wurde oder so. Aber wenn in der verschlüsselten Kommunikation, die ja einfach übers offene Internet geschickt wird, hinter Türen eingebaut wird, dann können eben auch beliebige Kriminelle im Zweifelsfall diese Informationen mitlesen und damit alles Mögliche anstellen.
Warte mal, also ist das, ist das Bild, also um beim Briefbild zu bleiben, ist das Bild also sozusagen, wenn ein Brief aufgemacht wird, wird ein Brief aufgemacht. Aber wenn man digitale Verschlüsselungen aufmacht, ist halt theoretisch sofort die gesamte Kommunikation offen und für jeden zu sehen, der Zugriff hat. Und man merkt nicht mal, dass daran jemand rumgespielt hat?
Ja, also erstes war jetzt gar nicht so mein Punkt. Mein Punkt war einfach nur, es haben theoretisch viel mehr Menschen auf diesen Kommunikationsstrom Zugriff, als tatsächlich Menschen physischen Zugriff auf die Briefe haben, die verschickt werden.
Es ist eben doch letztlich nicht so genau das Gleiche. Die Briefe haben und der Vergleich hinkt dir total, also der hinkt nicht, wenn du sagst, das ist eine Form, Kommunikation zu übermitteln und die ist auf eine gewisse Weise geschützt. Und zwar einerseits rechtlich geschützt und einerseits gewissermaßen mechanisch-technisch geschützt. Mechanisch der Brief durch den Umschlag, technisch die digitale Kommunikation durch die Verschlüsselung. Und da ist der Brief natürlich eine relativ schwache Form der Verschlüsselung, wenn du so willst, weil so ein Briefumschlag kann man sehr leicht aufmachen und das kann auch jeder. Da braucht man jetzt keine besonders technisches Wissen. Wo es aber auch hinkt, ist eben tatsächlich, das hat Julia gesagt, es gibt eine sehr übersichtliche Zahl von Menschen, für die das praktikabel ist, an diesen Brief zu kommen und ihn aufzumachen. Und das kommt vor und das wird auch gemacht. Und das ist auch ein Problem und das ist verboten. Und das lässt sich aber auch nicht ändern. Und bei der digitalen Kommunikation ist das Problem, wenn die technische Möglichkeit gegeben ist und auch vorgehalten wird und sozusagen in Umlauf gebracht ist oder eben nicht repariert wurde, dass jemand die Verschlüsselung bricht und den Inhalt mitliest, dann ergibt sich für sehr viel mehr Leute die Möglichkeit, den Zugriff auf diese Kommunikation zu haben. Weswegen es ein ganz starkes Bedürfnis danach gibt, zu sagen, es muss jede Möglichkeit, die Verschlüsselung zu umgehen, zum Beispiel in Form einer Sicherheitslücke, die befunden wird, muss einfach sofort geschlossen werden, damit nicht ganz viele Leute Zugriff auf die Kommunikation von ganz vielen anderen Leuten, Unternehmen, Gruppen und so weiter haben. Das ist der Vergleich, der trifft einfach nur ein Stück weit. Der trifft rechtlich, wenn man sagt oder argumentiert aus Perspektive von Strafverfolgungsbehörden, die sagen, aber wir müssen doch das mitlesen können. Aber der trifft überhaupt nicht zu, wenn sozusagen die möglichen Folgen des Zugriffs bedacht werden. Das ist so ein bisschen so was Ähnliches vielleicht, wie auch eine analoge oder eine digitale Kommunikation insofern unterschiedlich ist, als wir glaube ich alle wissen, dass wir bestimmte Sachen vielleicht nicht in E-Mails, in Foren, in Messenger-Gruppen oder so schreiben oder bestimmte Fotos da nicht rein posten. Weil wir genau wissen, der eine Klick, das zu kopieren und weiterzuschicken, der ist ganz schnell gemacht. Und das haben alle oder hoffentlich die meisten irgendwann mal gelernt, dass das was ganz anderes ist, als wenn ich so einen Satz auf eine Postkarte schreibe. Weil die Postkarte einfach überhaupt nicht in einem vergleichbaren Maße durch die Gegend wandern kann. Einfach durch unbedachtes Kopieren oder absichtliches Kopieren.
Dann frage ich mich gerade, ist aus aktivistischer Sicht dann auch ein Problem, dass die Verschlüsselung, Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung von Messengern zumindest, wurde ja ein großes Thema nach Snowden. Und wurde ja als ein Mittel angesehen, wenn wir alle immer unsere Kommunikation Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln, dann kann diese anlasslose Massenüberwachung, also Dienste lesen einfach alles, werfen das in einen großen Informationssee und fischen dann hinterher darauf rum und gucken, was wir da rausziehen können. Ist sozusagen die Angst oder ein Verdacht auch, dass dieses Aufweichen von Verschlüsselung auch das wieder möglich macht? Also, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, technisch ja sowieso, aber möglich machen soll auch?
Also was klar ist, man kann Verschlüsselung nicht vollständig verbieten. Es ist ja letzten Endes einfach ein mathematisches Verfahren. Das Wissen darüber ist in der Welt. Aber wenn es keine Messengerdienste gibt, die Verschlüsselung von Haus aus anbieten, dann ist es natürlich viel weniger Menschen praktisch zugänglich. Also ich jetzt zum Beispiel wüsste nicht, wie ich selber irgendwie meine Inhalte verschlüsselte und die dann irgendwie über einen unverschlüsselten Messenger verschicke. Oder da müsste ich mich erstmal irgendwie reinfuchsen. Und das werden sicherlich sehr wenige Leute machen. Und insofern, also wenn jetzt ein Verbot kommen würde für Unternehmen, die solche Messengerdienste anbieten, dass denen verboten wird, Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung zu implementieren, dann würde das dazu führen, dass insgesamt der Anteil der verschlüsselten Kommunikationen an der Internetkommunikation extrem zurückgehen würde. Und das hätte genau den Effekt, den du beschreibst. Also dass dann viel weniger verschlüsselt wird.
Ich bin jetzt unsicher, setzt du jetzt gerade unverschlüsselte Kommunikationen mit verschlüsselte Kommunikationen, bei der aber ein Nachschlüssel irgendwo liegt gleich?
Ach so, naja, das kommt drauf an, was genau die EU-Kommission da dann tatsächlich als Gesetzesentwurf vorlegen wird. Also ich habe jetzt eher von unverschlüsselter Kommunikation gesprochen.
Ach so, die Frage bezog sich darauf, dass von dem, was ich immer gehört habe zu diesen Papieren ist, die die Anbieter sollen einen Nachschlüssel irgendwo unterlegen, also eine Schnüffel-Schnittstelle installieren in ihren Plattformen. Und darauf bezog es ja Verdacht, aber letztlich kommt es natürlich auf dasselbe hinaus.
Ich glaube, natürlich können nicht alle Leute diese ganzen EU-Dokumente verfolgen und die Debatten dahinter und die verschiedenen Stränge. Und die meisten werden auch einzelne Papiere nicht gründlich lesen. Insofern ist es schon notwendig, das journalistisch verständlich runterzubrechen, was damit gemeint ist. Aber faktisch steht eben in dem Papier, über das wir reden, nicht genau drin, was gemacht werden soll. Und in vielen anderen auch nicht. Aus guten Gründen, weil eben vieles Verhandlungsfrage ist und auch in Staaten unterschiedlich umgesetzt wird und die Rechtsgrundlagen unterschiedlicher sind. Und weil es eben diese sehr kontroversen Interessen rund um dieses Thema gibt, wo die eine Seite immer sagt, Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung unbedingt. Die IT-Sicherheit, unser aller IT-Sicherheit, übrigens auch die Geschäftsgeheimnisse. Und die andere Seite eben sagt, wir müssen alles mitlesen können, diese schlimmen Dinge, das geht so nicht weiter. Und deswegen stehen da meistens keine konkreten Sachen drin, weil es sehr viel leichter wäre zu sagen, das werden wir einfach auf gar keinen Fall mittragen. Und deswegen stehen da auch nicht so konkrete Dinge drin, wie die sollen eine Hintertür vorhalten oder die sollen sich nicht eine Quellen-TKÜ ganz konkret bereitstellen oder so. Sondern es geht erstmal nur um die grundsätzliche Hinbewegung zu einer Akzeptanz von bestimmten Verschiebungen dieser Diskussion in Richtung, es soll doch endlich jetzt mitgelesen werden können.
Okay, ich würde das tatsächlich nochmal ganz explizit als Frage formulieren wollen. Vielleicht müssen wir dann doch sozusagen einen kleinen, also nicht nur über Verschüttelungen, sondern auch über EU-Politik sprechen. Weil ich habe neulich die Serie Parlament geschaut, auf Arte. Ich weiß, wenn ihr nicht gesehen habt, es ist eine sehr gute Serie. Das sage ich jetzt erstmal nur vom Unterhaltsamen her. Es geht um die Arbeit innerhalb des EU-Parlaments. Da wird sozusagen im Prinzip ein Referent eines Abgeordneten begleitet. Und der soll, es geht um einen Gesetzentwurf, irgendwas mit Fischen.
Haifisch-Flossen.
Genau, Haifisch-Flossen, irgendwas. Und die Serie ist auch ganz schön gedreht, weil alle Sprachen, die im Parlament gesprochen werden, sprechen die Leute dort auch. Und man kann das sozusagen mit Untertiteln gucken. Aber man wandert auch selber mit Sprachen hin und her. Und da wird dann Politik so dargestellt, es geht eigentlich nie um die Sache, sondern es geht immer nur darum, mit der Sache andere Dinge zu verkaufen oder zu erkaufen oder zu schachern. Und es macht so, also einerseits wirklich so ein bisschen sympathisch, weil das sind auch halt alles nur Menschen mit Plänen und Dingen. Und andererseits, wenn das wirklich eins zu eins ist, wie Politik funktioniert, ist es sehr, sehr seltsam. Aber vielleicht steckt da auch ein Kern der Wahrheit drin. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Es gibt also jetzt dieses Papier. Und es gibt gegen dieses Papier, ich weiß nicht, ob der Gegenwind stark ist, aber es beschäftigen sich die einschlägigen Menschen damit. Und zwar in einer Vehemenz, die nahe liegt, da passiert etwas Wichtiges. Trotzdem könnte man jetzt denken, naja, gut, also wenn man diese Debatte, die ja echt schon jetzt Jahrzehnte geht, verfolgt, ist eigentlich auch klar, wenn so ein Ding rauskommt, dann wird halt genau das passieren. Das heißt, dass das widerspruchsfrei umgesetzt wird. Damit müsste man den Menschen, die dieses Papier geschrieben haben, unterstellen, dass die das sehr wohl schon einberechnet haben, dass genau das passiert, dass die Leute darüber diskutieren, was sollte er schon wieder missen? Und dann frage ich mich wirklich, was ist die Motivation dahinter, so ein Papier zu schreiben?
Ich nehme das in der Stelle gar nicht wahr, als da ist jetzt plötzlich so ein totaler Knaller rausgekommen, obwohl das natürlich in gewisser Weise ist, weil man den jetzt plötzlich mitlesen kann und weil er wieder in diese Richtung schubst. Für mich ist das der 187. Schritt auf demselben Weg, wo alle paar Monate solche Dokumente entstehen und etwas verändert in die unterschiedlichen Gremien geschoben werden. Dasselbe gibt es im Bundestag bei den Diskussionen, wo gesagt wird, wir brauchen Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wir brauchen den Staatstrojaner, wir brauchen endlich, wir müssen die Messenger mitlesen können.
Das ist jetzt einer von diesen Schritten. Ich will gleich noch über die große Motivation sprechen. Du sagst also, das konkrete Papier, das ist einfach nur sozusagen ein Tropfen in das Fass. Der hat eigentlich gar kein konkretes Ziel, sondern einfach nur sozusagen das Ding weichklopfen.
Ist mein Gefühl. Mich würde Julias Einschätzung dazu total interessieren.
Ich will nicht nachfragen. Ich will jetzt Markus, weil er gerade draußen reinkommt, fragen, was ist denn dein Gefühl dazu, dieses konkrete Ding, worüber wir gerade reden, warum ist das gekommen? Halts du die Einschätzung auch oder siehst du das anders?
Wir hören ihn nicht.
Da sind böse Mächte im Spiel. Markus hört uns mittlerweile, aber wir hören ihn nicht. An mir liegt es nicht, ich schwöre. Julia, dann musst doch du...
Ich war zuerst gemutet. Ich hoffe, daran liegt es nicht. Wobei sich das leicht beheben ließe. Ich glaube, dass mit diesem Papier ein konkreterer Zweck verfolgt wird. Das liegt an dem Timing. Es wurde in der Presse berichtet, dass der Anlass für dieses Papier die jüngsten Terroranschläge in Österreich und Frankreich gewesen wären. Das ist aber nicht richtig. Der erste Entwurf des Papiers wurde schon davor verfasst. Den hatte auch Statewatch im September oder Oktober schon veröffentlicht. Es wurden dann nur noch mal nach dem Terroranschlag in Österreich Änderungen eingepflegt, die aber in der Grundaussage nichts geändert haben. Das heißt also, es war schon von etwas längerer Hand geplant. Der Grund oder dafür, meiner Ansicht nach, ist der Europäischen Kommission zu signalisieren von Seiten der Innenministerinnen, dass sie einen Gesetzesvorschlag in die Richtung haben möchten. Und das kommt jetzt nicht komplett von ungefähr, weil die EU-Kommission im Sommer auch dieses Strategiepapier zur Bekämpfung des Kindesmissbrauchs veröffentlicht hatte, indem sie genau so einen Gesetzesvorschlag ankündigt, und zwar für den Frühjahr nächsten Jahres. Und jetzt ist es ja so, dass wenn europäische Gesetzgebung verabschiedet werden soll, dann muss erst die EU-Kommission so einen Vorschlag erarbeiten. Und dann müssen sowohl Europaparlament als auch der Rat, also die Ministerinnen und Minister, dem zustimmen. Und die EU-Kommission verliert sehr ungern. Also das heißt, wenn sie Gesetzgebungen veröffentlichen, dann wollen sie auch, dass die gute Chancen hat, verabschiedet zu werden. Und deshalb ist es relativ üblich, dass das Europaparlament in solchen Resolutionen einfach seine Meinung zu Themenkund tut und damit ein Signal an die Kommission sendet. Bisschen weniger üblich, aber manchmal kommt es eben auch vor, dass auch der Rat das macht. Und genau das ist dieses Papier. Also darin sagt der Rat im Grunde genommen, wir stehen dem Thema Hintertüren in Verschlüsselung aufgeschlossen gegenüber. Mach doch mal einen Vorschlag.
Ich bin fassungslos. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber gut, Markus, können wir dich jetzt hören? Nein. Böse Mächte verhindern eine ausufernde Diskussion zu diesem Thema. Genau, kriegen wir jetzt leider nicht geklärt. Vielleicht klappt das zwischendurch nochmal. Jetzt ist er gerade wieder bei mir rausgeflogen. Es ist zum Verrücktwerden.
Ich könnte zwischendurch noch mit einer Fernsehserienbeobachtung eine Lücke überbrücken, derweil du versuchst, Markus wieder in diesen Stream mit zu integrieren. Weil tatsächlich, ich hab das Parlament auch gesehen, ich fand das sehr lustig, das fokussiert ganz doll darauf, dass mit welchen Tricksereien unterschiedliche Verhandlungsergebnisse erzielt werden, weil die einen das eine wollen, die anderen das andere wollen. Und dann machen sie total merkwürdige Kompromisse, die ja mit dem Inhalt dessen, worum es geht, überhaupt gar nichts mehr zu tun haben. Das ist ein Teil von parlamentarischer Politik, der da wahnsinnig überzeichnet ist und den es aber in allen anderen politischen Prozessen in der Form auch gibt. Da könnte man eine eigene Sendung drüber machen. Das klingt ganz furchtbar. Ich finde, es gibt manchmal gute Gründe, warum das so ist. Ich hab kürzlich eine andere Serie gesehen, wo so was Ähnliches thematisiert wurde. Und zwar The Crown, die gerade auf Netflix die vierte Staffel gestartet haben. Wo ein bisschen ein anderer Aspekt von sowas beleuchtet wurde. Und zwar geht es darum, dass Maggie Thatcher im Commonwealth damit konfrontiert ist, dass die ganzen Commonwealth-Daten Sanktionen gegen Südafrika in den 90ern haben wollen. Und sie will partout keine Sanktionen, weil sie ja gute Geschäfte mit Südafrika machen kann. Und da gibt es ein Papier, und das wird in dieser Folge, in dieser vierten Staffel sehr ausführlich dargestellt, wo die ganzen Commonwealth-Regierungschefs um sie rumstehen und sagen, wir wollen Sanktionen. Und sie sagt, auf gar keinen Fall. Und dann geht das zehnmal hin und her. Und die sagen, wir wollen, dann wollen wir Maßnahmen. Dann wollen wir irgendwas anderes. Und sie sagt immer Nein. Und zum Schluss sagen die, na gut, dann nehmen wir halt Signals, also Signale, die ausgesendet werden an Südafrika. Und dann sagt Maggie, ja, das ist in Ordnung. Und alle sind total glücklich, dass sie sie endlich rumgekriegt haben. Und hinterher grinst sie dann ganz fies und sagt, na ja, Signale können ja auch positive Signale sein. Und ich fand, das beleuchtet total gut, dass bestimmte solche Verhandlungen einfach total lange dauern. Und dann scheinbar nur noch um so ganz kleinen Kleinkram gehen, wo irgendwelche Sachen ausgetragen werden. Und das hat mich, das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an das, was hier rund um diese Verschlüsselungsdebatte stattfindet, wo immer wieder aus unterschiedlichen Richtungen versucht wird, einen Millimeter vorwärtszukommen bei diesem wir müssen die verschlüsselten Messenger knacken. Jetzt versuchen wir es von hier und jetzt versuchen wir es von hier und jetzt versuchen wir es von hier. Und irgendwann wird dann da eine Formulierung sein, die diesen totalen Interessensgegensatz, der da heißt, auf der einen Seite wollen wir sichere Verschlüsselung und auf der anderen Seite wollen wir mitlesen können. Das steckt ja schon in dem Titel von dem Ding drin. Also Sicherheit mit Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung. Das beschreibt das Problem, das geht nicht beides. Es wird da keine Kompromisslösung geben können, aber der Versuch wird halt weiter gemacht, weil sie es halt einfach so dolle wollen. Und das hängt, glaube ich, von uns ganz stark ab, dass wir weiter total dagegenhalten auf allen Ebenen, die wir können.
Wie wir das machen, bespreche ich auf jeden Fall auch noch. Jetzt ist Markus da, glaube ich. So, ich habe jetzt gerade gefragt, was die Vermutung war, was die Motivation war, genau dieses Papier rauszubringen. Und ich fasse nur mal grob zusammen, es geht letztlich darum, diesen Städten-Tropfen-Strom- Verschlüsselung aufzuweichen, ein bisschen anschwellen zu lassen. Julia hat gerade ganz anschaulich erklärt, dass das aber durchaus was ganz Konkretes ist, was aber der längerfristige Planung ist. Was ich von euch allen dreien auch machen würde, ich würde jetzt mit Markus anfangen, solange er noch da ist, dieses Thema Verschlüsselung aufzuweichen, Überwachung an den Start bringen, das ist ja eben genau schon sehr lange da. Und angebracht werden halt immer diese Sicherheitsaspekte, also Terroristen fangen, wo man sich fragt, ja Moment mal, gerade in Wien war doch jetzt gerade wieder so, da war doch eigentlich alles klar. Da ist halt nur nicht ordentlich mit Informationen, die da waren, gearbeitet worden. Was sollte das da jetzt helfen? Und dann so Themen wie Kindesmisshandlung, wo man ganz schlecht sagen kann, das ist kein guter Grund. Aber trotzdem liegt es dann da verquer. Und deswegen an euch die Frage, warum machen die das? Glauben die das wirklich oder steckt dahinter ein anderer Plan? Das ist mir nicht ganz klar, weil wenn man diese Debatte, Verschüsselung, Nicht-Verschüsselung, verfolgt hat, und die geht ja wirklich schon sehr, sehr lange, dann hat man ja alle Argumente gehört. Und es gibt ja sozusagen eben dieses eine, man kann Verschüsselung nicht so ein bisschen aufweichen, sondern man kann ja kaputt machen oder nicht. Warum ist das so, Marcus? Was glaubst du? Steckt da sozusagen so ein Sicherheitsbedürfnis für oder ist das was anderes?
Das ist auch einfach ein Blickwinkel. Wenn man gewohnt ist, dass Sicherheitsbehörden SMS mitlesen können, dann ist es manchen Leuten schwer zu erklären, warum das bei WhatsApp oder Telegram nicht machbar sein sollte. Also es gibt einfach den Anspruch zu sagen, die Sicherheitsbehörden haben für bestimmte Straftaten die Möglichkeit, Kommunikation zu überwachen. Und dann ist quasi der Wunsch, dass die Technik das entsprechend abbildet. Und da ist gar kein tieferes Verständnis von der Verschlüsselung dahinter. Sondern lediglich, die sollten das Recht haben, das zu tun, und dann muss es auch irgendwie gehen. Und da wird nicht groß über Verschlüsselung gesprochen oder über die Knackbarkeit von bestimmten Protokollen oder der Schaden, der dort entsteht, wird so nicht gesehen. Also wenn ich keine Verschlüsselung habe für die Wirtschaft oder für die Zivilgesellschaft, habe ich ja quasi Folgeschäden. Aber die werden dort nicht gesehen. Und jetzt haben wir so eine ganze Reihe von Vorhaben, die Terec-Richtlinie für Tera Inhalte, die CSAM-Pakete für KIPO und die weitere Debatten rund um Uploadfilter oder das Filtern von Content, wo sozusagen technische Maßnahmen jetzt eingerichtet werden sollen, damit dann auch die Provider die Möglichkeit haben, zentral auf Inhalte zuzugreifen. Also da greifen gerade momentan mehrere Verfahren ineinander. Die technische Basis ist ja, wenn ich Tera Inhalte entfernen möchte, muss ich auch erst mal sehen können, was drin ist.
Jetzt muss ich doch noch ein Zeichen drauf machen, weil du gerade gesagt hast Uploadfilter. Uploadfilter ist ja eigentlich was anderes. Bei Uploadfiltern geht es ja eigentlich darum, im geringsten Schlimmenfalle Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu erkennen, wenn sie erst hochgeladen werden. Macht das auch Verschüsselung kaputt oder ist das eine andere Baustelle? Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht ganz.
Das ist eigentlich eine andere Baustelle, was eigentlich für öffentliche Internetplattformen gemacht worden ist. Aber der Wunsch, größere Messenger-Kanäle damit zu filtern, war halt auch da. Es gibt ja durchaus Kanäle, in denen mehrere Zehntausende von Menschen sind, wo ja auch von einer gewissen Öffentlichkeit gesprochen werden kann. Und damit auch von der Verbreitung von Inhalten.
Ich glaube, es gibt auch noch eine andere Überschneidung zwischen den beiden Themen. Und zwar bei der Bekämpfung von dokumentiertem Kindesmissbrauch. Weil einer der Anlässe dafür, warum die EU-Kommission jetzt dieses Thema wieder aufgegriffen hat, ist, dass ab Ende des Jahres die ePrivacy-Richtlinie auch für Messenger-Dienste gelten wird. Und das bedeutet dann eben, dass die Plattformbetreiber, also zum Beispiel Facebook, im Fall vom Facebook Messenger, nicht mehr ohne Zustimmung die Kommunikation mitlesen dürfen. Und bisher setzt Facebook halt so einen Upload-Filter ein. Also das ist kein Upload-Filter, der Inhalte sperrt, sondern das ist einer, der Inhalte erkennt. Also eine Inhalte-Erkennungstechnologie. Das heißt, da gibt es eine Referenzdatenbank von bekannten Bildern von Kindesmissbrauch. Und wenn die jemanden über Facebook-Messenger verschickt, dann kann dieser Filter das erkennen. Und dann ist Facebook informiert und Facebook kann die Sicherheitsbehörden informieren. Und durch das Inkrafttreten der Reform, die jetzt Ende des Jahres kommt, also dem Telekommunikationskodex, darf Facebook das nicht mehr so ohne Weiteres machen. Also die können nicht mehr einfach ohne Zustimmung der Person, die da kommunizieren, einfach irgendwelche Filter einsetzen. Und wie Markus schon gesagt hat, also wenn Sicherheitsbehörden gewohnt sind, dass sie bestimmte Möglichkeiten für Ermittlungen haben, dann ist es sehr, sehr schwer zu vermitteln, dass sie die plötzlich nicht mehr haben sollen. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass die EU-Kommission jetzt schon einen Vorschlag vorgelegt hat für ein Gesetz, das einfach diese Ausweitung des Datenschutzes rückgängig machen soll, um eben Facebook weiterhin zu ermöglichen, diese Filter einzusetzen. Das ist der erste Schritt. Aber Facebook Messenger ist ja überhaupt nicht verschlüsselt. Insofern hat das mit Verschlüsselung erstmal nichts zu tun. Aber das war jetzt auch der Anlass dafür, dass die EU-Kommission eben angekündigt hat, okay, in einem zweiten Schritt möchten wir, dass diese Filter halt nicht nur auf Messenger eingesetzt werden, sondern auch zum Beispiel auf WhatsApp. Und um das tun zu können, müssen Hintertüren in die Verschlüsselung rein. Also so hängen dann die Themen Upload-Filter und Verschlüsselung auch wieder miteinander zusammen.
Ähm, jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, also bei der Terrorabwehr, finde ich, wenn man das so verfolgt, da kann man, also Terrorabwehr als angeblicher Grund für die Aufweichung von. Find ich, da gibt es immer so Gegenbeispiele, wo man sagen kann, naja, also gerade Wien jetzt wieder, es gibt immer so, ihr habt eigentlich genug Krams, mit dem ihr arbeiten könnt, verwendet doch das erst mal ordentlich, bevor man irgendwas anderes macht. Also mal abgesehen davon, dass das keine gute Argumentation ist, weil man dann immer in Aussicht stellt, wenn das nicht klappt, dann vielleicht doch. Aber bei Kindesmissbrauch, also das Ansinnen sozusagen, das ist ja verständlich oder nicht?
Ja, natürlich, aber das Ansinnen Terrorbekämpfung ist auch verständlich. Ich glaube, in beiden Fällen gibt es bessere.
Aber da gibt es andere Mittel.
Ja, aber doch bei der Bekämpfung des Kindesmissbrauchs auch. Solange der Staat öffentliche Mittel für Frauenhäuser kürzt, kann man niemand erzählen, dass alles getan wird, um Kindesmissbrauch zu bekämpfen.
Da würde ich jetzt politisch schon wieder sagen, aha. Das heißt also, wenn man sagt, Kindesmissbrauch können wir aufklären, indem wir die digitale Verschlüsselung aufweichen, ob wir diese Uploadfilter installieren. Treibt denn also nicht nur die Agenda vorne an, das endlich mal zu schaffen, nämlich Kommunikation nicht überwachbar zu machen, sondern lenkt auch noch ab vom eigentlichen Grund für schlimme Dinge?
Soweit würde ich gar nicht gehen. Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass diejenigen, die diese Reform fordern, irgendwie gute Absichten dabei haben. Es ist halt bloß nicht möglich, die Verschlüsselung ausschließlich für lautere Zwecke aufzubrechen. Also wenn man einmal Hintertüren in die Verschlüsselung einbaut, dann ist es technisch nicht möglich zu sagen, diese Hintertür gilt jetzt ausschließlich für dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch. Das ist einfach nicht machbar. Also in dem Moment, wo die Verschlüsselung nicht mehr Ende zu Ende ist, könnte Facebook dann eben auch zu beliebigen anderen Zwecken unsere Kommunikation mitlesen.
Aber das könnte man in solchen Leuten erklären. Sagen sie dann so, das stimmt einfach nicht, oder das sehe ich anders, das ist kein Argument. Das verstehe ich halt nicht.
Das ist ja in der Geschichte der sogenannten Crypto Wars, also der Kriege um die Verschlüsselung, die seit Jahrzehnten in Wellen wiederkommen. Ist das ja kein neues Argument. Das ist ja zigmal gesagt und zigmal ausgetauscht worden. Wenn ihr eine Lücke in die Ende zur Endeverschlüsselung macht, dann wird das unsicher. Wenn ihr Sicherheitslücken nicht schließt, dann können auch andere mitlesen. Das ist sozusagen allen Seiten bekannt. Ich glaube, was wahrscheinlich auch niemandem tatsächlich eine überraschende Neuigkeit ist, wir stehen ja nicht einem monolithischen Block gegenüber. Das wäre einfach sozusagen zu sagen, alle auf der Gegenseite haben ein und dasselbe Interesse. Die EU, das Parlament, der Bundestag, der Verfassungssturz, das BKA und so weiter sind natürlich auch unterschiedliche Institutionen, die teilweise gemeinsam in dieselbe Richtung laufen, aber natürlich dann auch teilweise unterschiedliche Interessen haben. Und natürlich gibt es auch bei Straferfolgungsbehörden völlig aufrechte Strafverfolger, die tatsächlich einfach sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Kinder bekämpfen wollen und ich glaube nicht wenige und aus guten Gründen. Und dann sagen, das ist uns aber einfach unendlich viel wichtiger als diese unselige Debatte über IT-Sicherheit. Was soll das? Das ist vielleicht einfach nicht ihr Fokus. Und so gibt es da einfach Interessen, die teilweise zusammenspielen und teilweise einfach nicht. Es ist also diese Verschwörungstheorie, dass die sich alle zusammentun. Und die unterstelle ich jetzt hier gerade niemandem, aber die sozusagen, ich finde manchmal, wenn man über diese Fragen nachdenkt, dann klingt das so ein bisschen durch, als ob da alle immer ganz homogen dasselbe wollen. Das ist einfach nicht der Fall. Und solche Argumente, wie Julia gesagt hat, wenn die immer das Problem mit der Gewalt gegen Kinder hochhalten und das glaube ich auch wirklich bekämpfen wollen, also jedenfalls einige andere, wiederum vielleicht auch nicht. Es gibt ja auch eine ganze Menge Leute, die Gewalt gegen Kinder verüben. Auch sicherlich in Sicherheitsbehörden. Das führt jetzt ab und weg. Das sind einfach nicht die Leute beispielsweise, die Gewalt gegen Frauen oder die Auswirkungen von Gewalt gegen Frauen mit Bezug auf Gewalt gegen Kinder überhaupt sich damit befassen. Das sind völlig andere Institutionen, die das tun. Und deswegen, jetzt verliere ich mich so ein bisschen.
Also ich versuche mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, weil kommt dann wieder. Es ist nicht so, dass es eine große, sinistre Verschwörung gibt, die Verschlüsselungen abschaffen wird und wo sozusagen, also wir gegen die, die gibt es halt sozusagen nicht, sondern es gibt aus verschiedenen Gründen die Motivationen oder sogar den Glauben daran, dass das eigentlich eine ganz gute Sache ist, weil es viele Dinge einfacher macht.
Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich schon, und das glaube ich auch, einfach Geheimdienste und Sicherheitsbehörden, die da einfach eine sehr starke Kraft drin sind, die auf jeden Fall vor allen Dingen einfach alles mitlesen können wollen. Und die einen wahnsinnig starken Einfluss haben auf Politik, weil sie natürlich auch sehr dicht dran sind und weil sie eben für die Sicherheit zuständig sind.
Okay, bevor wir gleich dazu kommen, was man dagegen machen kann, würde ich gerne fragen, die Cryptowars, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, die sind ja in den frühen 90ern losgegangen. Und das hat ja dazu geführt, dass man bestimmte Arten von Verschlüsselungen, also Verschlüsselungsprogrammen nicht mehr benutzen durfte. Und dann wiederum haben Menschen Computerprogramme in eine Zahl umgewandelt und die auf einen T-Shirt gedruckt. Und so konnte man das Programm doch verbreiten. Und weil man Mathematik kann man nicht verbieten und so weiter und so fort. Ich würde fragen wollen, gesetzt den Fall, das Ding wird jetzt so umgesetzt, wie man das lesen und vermuten kann. Also Betreiber von Messengern werden verpflichtet, Nachschlüssel einzubauen in ihre Plattform. Dann ist es ja denkbar, dass es trotzdem dezentrale Messenger gibt, die durch ihren Programmiercode erlauben, Ende zu Ende Verschüttelung zu machen. Wären die dann verboten?
Das kommt drauf an, was in dem Vorschlag steht. Also es gibt im Moment keinen Gesetzesvorschlag. Insofern ist es immer ein bisschen hypothetisch zu fragen, also was wäre dann genau verboten. Aber klar, wenn in dem Gesetzesvorschlag zum Beispiel drinstehen würde, dass kommerzielle Betreiber von Messengerplattformen, die ihren Sitz in der EU haben, das machen müssen, dann würde das zum Beispiel Leute nicht daran hindern, Messengerdienste zu nutzen, die ihren Sitz außerhalb der EU haben. Oder eben dezentrale Messengerdienste. Aber das hängt immer davon ab, was denn dann in dem Gesetz drinsteht. Und das wissen wir zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt nicht, weil es eben erstmal nur so eine Willensbegründung ist.
Ich glaube, es gibt da so einen schönen Satz, der das Problem gut beschreibt, der da heißt, wenn Verschlüsselung verboten wird, dann nutzen nur noch Verbrecherverschlüsselung. Also die Leute, die wirklich wollen, die können verschlüsseln. Und für alle anderen wird das Netz aber viel, viel unsicherer. Weil die sich vielleicht einfach nicht den Zugang, weil die nicht das technische Wissen, weil die auch nicht die Energie haben, sich darum zu kümmern. Dann jeweils die aktuelle sichere Version von Messengern tatsächlich zu benutzen. Das heißt, für ganz viele Leute wird das Kommunizieren unsicherer. Aber das, was eigentlich gefunden werden soll, die werden sich zu einem großen Teil andere Wege suchen können.
Es gibt ja auch viele Behörden, die aktiv Verschlüsselung bewerben. Das Auswärtige Amt macht ja zum Beispiel auch Werbung für Journalisten oder für Menschenrechtsaktivisten, dass sie sichere Software nutzen und fördert auch in diesem Rahmen Projekte in Staaten mit Regimen, wo man vielleicht auch lieber Verschlüsselung möchte. Entsprechend gibt es halt auch viele Behörden, die sozusagen gegen das BMI arbeiten und eine andere Position dazu haben. Also die Position der Bundesregierung hat immer so eine Dualität aus zum einen im Inneren das BMI aufbrechen und gleichzeitig nach außen bewerben und die freie Welt nach außen tragen.
Ich finde eins, was auch noch mit dazu gehört, was ich da gerne einfach noch mit erwähnen will. Wir reden immer ganz viel über Hintertüren und warum die Hintertüren ein Problem sind. Ich glaube zumindest die deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden sind davon weg. Die haben verstanden, dass das mit den Hintertüren ein Problem ist und dass sie das vielleicht nicht durchkriegen. Seit einer gerauben Weile läuft mindestens das BKA durch die Gegend. Sagt, wir wollen keine Hintertüren. Also sozusagen wie das unschuldige Engelchen zu Weihnachten am Baum. Hintertüren? Nein, würden wir nie machen. Wir wollen Vordertüren. Was?
Generalschlüsseln.
Das ist auch noch nicht ausbuchstabiert. Jedenfalls nicht in öffentlich zugänglichen, mir bekannten Dokumenten. Ich bin ganz sicher, dass es da einiges dazu gibt. Und auch unterschiedliche Ideen. Da sind wir wieder dabei. Es gibt noch keinen konkreten Vorschlag, was es sein soll. Aber natürlich wird schon lange darüber nachgedacht. Und eine von diesen Ideen ist, dass anstelle von Sicherheitslücken oder bereitgestellten Hintertüren für die gesamte Software, das vielleicht über die Provider oder die Appstores gelöst wird, sodass in dem Moment, wo eine bestimmte Zielperson überwacht werden soll, die beim Update ihrer Messenger-Software nicht die tatsächliche Messenger-Software bekommt aus dem Appstore, die sie gerne haben will, sondern eine leicht veränderte, für sie zugeschnittene Überwachungssoftware.
Ja, da gibt es ja sozusagen dieses schöne Bild, was man auf dem Netz gesehen hat, mit dem Garten und der sicheren Eingangstür. Und daneben ist halt dann so eine Hecke auf 10 cm Höhe. So ähnlich ist es ja auch bei der Verschlüsselung. Die Verschlüsselung selbst muss man ja oft gar nicht knacken oder brechen. Es gibt ja oft viele weitere Möglichkeiten, an die Inhalte der Nachrichten ranzukommen. Also zum Beispiel ein klassisches Mittel der Polizei ist, Dinge zu beschlagnahmen und mitzunehmen. Und wenn wir irgendwas aus den letzten Jahren gelernt haben, liest die Samen öfter mal Handys ein. Und dann ist da halt der Gruppenchat drin der letzten drei, vier Jahre. Deswegen gibt es ja jetzt auch momentan recht viele Verfahren im Bereich strafbare Inhalte in den Polizeichatgruppen. Also es gibt ja da durchaus immer Möglichkeiten, auch sozusagen retrograd an die Inhalte ranzukommen. Gleichzeitig gab es eine ganze Zeit lang auch bald den Messenger die Möglichkeit, zum Beispiel in einem Gruppenchat weitere Teilnehmer hinzuzufügen. Oder es gab ja Lücken, die man quasi ausnutzen konnte. Warte mal, ich muss kurz fragen.
Wenn du sagst, weitere Teilnehmer hinzuzufügen, meinst du in einem Gruppenchat wird ein Teilnehmer hinzugefügt, und der liest dann mit und leitet die Nachrichten aus?
Genau, da muss man ja quasi nur mal kurz Zugriff haben auf dem Handy und fügt jemanden hinzu. Oder das macht man klassischerweise auch mit verdeckten Ermittlern, die dann in solchen Chats mit unterwegs sind. Es gab auch eine ganze Zeit lang solche Sicherheitslücken, dass Apps bestimmte zwei Faktor-Keys brauchten per SMS. Nichts ist für die Polizei einfacher, als SMS abzufangen und sich dann ein Zweitgerät zuzulegen, um weitere Accounts sozusagen freischalten zu können, zum Beispiel mit WhatsApp Web auf die Nachrichten, ohne dann das Handy zu haben. Also da gab es durchaus sozusagen Wege, an ihnen heranzukommen, auch ohne die Verschlüsselung als solches zu brechen. Zum Zweiten ist sozusagen das Wichtigste auch immer das Schlüsselmanagement, also woher weiß ich eigentlich, wer hat welchen Schlüssel und an wen schicke ich die Nachricht. Früher hat man das mit den PGP-E-Mails immer so gemacht, dass man den Fingerprint verglichen hat und den Offizietenkarten gedruckt hat. Das macht man ja bei den Messenger-Diensten heutzutage nicht mehr. Und das ist so ein Angriffspunkt, wo halt die Provider rangehen können und dann für bestimmte C-Personen falsche Schlüssel rausgeben können. Und das wäre halt so eine Vorlertür, wo man quasi über den zentralen Dienst die Verschlüsselung umgehen kann, ohne sie brechen zu müssen. Das ist ja das, was quasi propagiert wird.
Das ist ganz frustrierend. Aber okay, wenn man jetzt... Ich weiß gerade, ob die Frage noch Sinn macht. Ich hatte sie mir vorgenommen, aber jetzt frage ich mich, ob sie Sinn macht. Ich frage sie trotzdem. Und zwar, was ich ja lerne, ist sozusagen, dass es alles Teil eines langgehegten Planes, einer stetigen Aktion. Macht es Sinn, da jetzt Widerstand an den Tag zu legen? Und wenn ja, wie macht man das? Außer, dass man sich hier drüber reden und versuchen, viele Leute darüber aufzuklären. Wenn ich jetzt HörerInnen dieses Podcast bin, denke, fuck, ich will was tun. Was tue ich dann?
Vielleicht vorweg noch mal kurz, macht das Sinn? Natürlich macht das Sinn. Diese Auseinandersetzung gab es auch schon vor dem Internet. Polizei will mir überwachen.
Ich will kurz erklären, woher die Frage kommt. Nichts macht das Sinn, sich dagegen zu wehren, die der eigenen Bezügerung widersprechen. Aber es könnte auch der Eindruck entstanden sein, der politische Alltag ist unter anderem auch. Es gibt immer wieder Leute, die Verschüßlung folgen. Dann gibt es andere Leute, die sagen, das ist Quatsch. Und deswegen die Frage, ist das einfach so eine Diskussion, die einfach immer wieder läuft, oder ist es sinnvoll, jetzt in diesem Moment aktiv zu werden?
Ich denke, es ist sinnvoll, jetzt im Moment aktiv zu werden, weil die EU-Kommission ja bereits angekündigt hat, dass sie nächstes Jahr so einen Gesetzesvorschlag präsentieren will. Wo ich im Moment relativ optimistisch bin, ist, dass das Europaparlament so was nicht zustimmen würde. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem wichtig, dass das Thema öffentlich präsent ist. Also ich glaube, in den Medien drüber zu reden, ist total wichtig. Auch mit seinen Abgeordneten drüber zu reden, ist wichtig. Ich fürchte halt, die Innenminister, also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt es das, aber mir selber ist irgendwie noch nie eine Innenministerin oder ein Innenminister begegnet, der sich irgendwie besonders für den Schutz der Grundrechte engagiert. Insofern ist einfach meine Hoffnung ins Parlament viel, viel höher als in den Rat. Aber insofern würde ich sagen, ja es lohnt sich jetzt aktiv zu werden und eben vor allen Dingen einerseits die öffentliche Diskussion anzufachen. Das macht auch einen Eindruck auf die EU-Kommission, wenn sie irgendwie das Gefühl hat, das ist was, was ganz unpopulär ist. Als ich im Parlament war zum Beispiel, da hatten wir halt den Vizepräsidenten der EU-Kommission für Digitales, der immer ganz klipp und klar gesagt hat, also Hintertüren in Schlüsselungen kommen für ihn nicht in Frage. Es wäre natürlich total super, solche klaren Aussagen auch von der aktuellen Kommission zu bekommen. Ja, und bei den Europa-Abgeordneten, denke ich, ist man da auch nicht an der falschen Adresse. Weil da habe ich noch relativ große Hoffnung, dass die sowas tatsächlich ablehnen würden, wenn es dann so einen Vorschlag geben sollte.
Ja, also diese ganz konkreten Sachen, alles richtig. Ich wollte sozusagen einerseits sagen, Sinn macht das immer, weil die eine Seite, die pusht halt die ganze Zeit. Und wenn da niemand gegenhält, dann gehen die halt schrittchenweise vorwärts. Und alleine das ist gewissermaßen einfach der Grund, den wir haben, dagegen zu halten. Und das andere, die Älteren unter uns erinnern sich, dass die aktuelle Kommissionspräsidentin mal als Zensursula bekannt geworden ist und auch schon beim Thema Kinderpornografie sehr engagiert war und dann aber auch kräftig auf die Nase gefallen ist. Und ich finde das ein überraschender Zufall, dass dieselbe Person jetzt gerade wieder mit dem Thema Kinderpornografie in genau diesem Bereich Internet-Sicherheit und Überwachung große Schritte vorwärtsgehen soll. Und ich hoffe, dass das mithilft, da so ein paar Energien wieder zu mobilisieren, die seit einer Weile so ein bisschen vor sich hinschlafen. Also die Netzcommunity hier bei uns, die war schon mal aktiver. Das hat bei den Upload-Filtern zwischendurch noch mal wieder sich so ein bisschen bewegt. Aber es reicht einfach nicht, wenn wir uns zurücklehnen und sagen, ja, das haben wir immer schon gesagt, so ist es halt. Sondern tatsächlich ist es wahnsinnig nötig, jetzt aktiver zu werden. Einerseits wegen dieser EU-Aktivitäten und aber ja, weil wir das in Deutschland im Bereich des Bundestages und der Bundesregierung ganz genauso auch haben. Und übrigens ja auch demnächst ein Wahlkampf auf uns zukommt, wo es umso mehr wichtig ist, von allen Parteien ganz klare Aussagen zu fordern, wie sie sich zu diesen Dingen verhalten und ganz klar deutlich zu machen, dass diese Bewegung, die es da gab, die es in der Größe nicht mehr gibt, aber nicht völlig tot ist.
Ja, es ist ja auch so, dass solche Positionen oder Festlegungen ja auch immer wieder neu ausgehandelt werden müssen. Also was wir vor 20 Jahren gesprochen haben, inzwischen sind viele neue Leute im Parlament seit dieser Zeit. Es sind viele neue Leute in den Ministerien, viele neue Leute auch in der Kommission, die zum Teil diese Debatten gar nicht kennen. Und natürlich muss man deswegen auch diese Debatten regelmäßig immer wieder öffentlich führen, damit dann auch das Bewusstsein dafür geschaffen wird, dass es dadurch diese Probleme gibt. Denn natürlich ist das so ein Thema, was nicht einmal erledigt sein kann, sondern es wird immer wieder aufgemacht werden von verschiedenen Playern. Und da muss man halt dazu, ja, sich dafür einsetzen, dass es halt nicht kippt und wir dann quasi Regelungen kriegen, die wir nicht haben wollen.
Ich will nochmal an Julia und Anne fragen, weil, also Julia, du warst der Abgeordnete, Anne, du arbeitest für eine Fraktion im Bundestag. Dieses, man hört das ja immer, das ist immer sozusagen immer ein aktiven Ratschlag, den man bekommt, nämlich kontaktiert die Abgeordnete. Wie macht man das auf eine Art und Weise, wo man dann nicht in Verdacht gerät, okay, jetzt hab ich seine Mail hingeschrieben, aber ist auch egal, oder jemand angerufen, aber ist auch egal, gibt es dann einen Weg? Oder ist das sowas, wo man sagen muss, naja, du darfst jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass es deine Mail ist, dass es dein Anruf ist, sondern wenn das einfach du und 150 Leute machen, dann ist es halt krass und deswegen ist es halt wichtig, dass es jeder Einzelne macht. Oder als Konzept mal erklärt, weil ich kenne tatsächlich immer nur den einzelnen Ratschlag, aber nicht, wie es konkret funktioniert.
Also ich würde sagen, es kommt total drauf an. Wenn man E-Mails schickt oder in Abgeordnetenbüros anruft, dann ist es vergleichsweise selten der Fall, dass man dann direkt die Abgeordneten ans Telefon bekommt. Also kommt durchaus auch mal vor, aber meistens spricht man da mit dem Büro. Ein Weg, wie man tatsächlich dafür sorgt, dass das Thema bei den Abgeordneten selber ankommt, ist auf Wahlkampfveranstaltungen Fragen zu stellen. Das haben zum Beispiel bei der Europawahl 2019 ganz, ganz viele Leute gemacht. Also alle deutschen Europaabgeordneten wissen über das Thema Upload-Filter Bescheid, weil sie einfach im Europawahlkampf dutzende Male auf jeder kleinsten Wahlkampfveranstaltung irgendwo auf dem Land von jungen Leuten danach gefragt wurden. Und das macht auf jeden Fall einen Eindruck. Auf der anderen Seite will ich aber auch gar nicht Leute davon abhalten, auch mal Abgeordneten in Büros anzurufen. Ich glaube schon, dass das was bringt. Vor allen Dingen, weil auch gar nicht so viele Leute diese Möglichkeit in Anspruch nehmen. Also es ist schon so, zumindest im Europaparlament, dass wenn man da anruft und die Telefonnummern kann man auf der Webseite des Europaparlament nachschauen, dass man in der Regel schon jemanden ans Telefon bekommt und die sich dann zumindest auch so ein paar Minuten Zeit nehmen, um sich das Einlegen anzuhören. Es bringt natürlich immer mehr, wenn man irgendeinen Grund hat, warum das jetzt für diese Person relevant ist. Also wenn man zu einer bestimmten Interessengruppe gehört, am besten halt aus dem richtigen Wahlkreis kommt und sagt, ist für meine Wahlentscheidung relevant oder so. Oder man kann das Ganze natürlich auch über Verbände machen. Also wenn man irgendwie Mitglied ist in einer Gewerkschaft oder in einem Verein, kann man natürlich auch versuchen, diese Organisationen dazu zu bekommen, sich an Abgeordnete zu wenden, weil das natürlich nochmal einen größeren Impact hat. Also wenn ihr jetzt eine ganze Gewerkschaft oder einen ganzen Berufsverband aus dem Bereich IT-Sicherheit zum Beispiel so ein Schreiben schickt oder um einen Termin bittet, dann macht das natürlich auch nochmal mehr Eindruck.
Anne, im Bundestag genauso?
In Variation natürlich, klar. Das mit den Wahlkampfveranstaltungen finde ich auch eine sehr, sehr kluge Idee. Also Leute tatsächlich konkret bei solchen Gelegenheiten fragen, wo man dann direkt mit ihnen sprechen kann. Was oft gemacht wird, wo ich so ein bisschen skeptisch bin, sind so Massen-Mail-Aktionen. Das kann auch schon mal eine Wirksamkeit haben, wenn wo ankommt, dass da einfach wahnsinnig viele Leute sind, die sich für ein Thema interessieren. Das kann aber auch, also es gibt effektivere Methoden, würde ich sagen. Wir haben das jetzt gerade gesehen. Da ist das von den Querdenkern passiert zum Bevölkerungsschutzgesetz. Da ist der gesamte Bundestag mit Massenhaft-E-Mails komplett blockiert worden. Die Abgeordneten haben Tausende von den Dingern am Tag bekommen. Da kriegen die einfach nur mit. Da gibt es eine konzertierte Aktion. Da gibt es irgendeine Organisation dahinter. Aber da wird sowas sozusagen natürlich nicht einzeln gelesen und beantwortet, sondern nur mal registriert. Da gibt es viele Leute, die sich interessieren. Das kann auch effektiv sein. Wenn man tatsächlich selber eine Mail hinschreibt, ist es glaube ich schon den meisten Abgeordnetenbüros so, dass die so eine Policy haben, dass sie sagen, wir versuchen das auf irgendeine Art und Weise zu beantworten. Vielleicht nicht zwei Stunden Recherche, aber natürlich wird das gelesen und wird auch beantwortet. Und was, finde ich, viel zu wenig genutzt wird, ist der Versuch, ins Gespräch zu kommen oder eigene Anliegen vorzutragen. Das wird von Lobbyverbänden, Unternehmensverbänden total massiv gemacht, dass die ankommen und sagen, wir würden gerne mal mit ihnen ein Gespräch haben über dies, das und jenes. Und NGOs machen das von sich aus im Netzbereich quasi überhaupt nicht. Es gibt jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viele, und die sind alle unterausgestattet und haben auch wenig Zeit dafür und haben wahrscheinlich in ihren Projektförderungen für sowas auch kein Geld. Das ist schon auch alles klar. Aber dieses aktiv auf Abgeordnete zugehen und sagen, wir haben folgendes Anliegen. Wir wollen, dass sie sich für dies und das einsetzen. Wir erklären es ihnen auch gerne nochmal. Und hier ist noch ein Textbaustein, warum das wichtig ist. Das machen Verbände morgens, mittags und abends. Und AktivistInnen machen das nicht. Und das ist ein Riesenverlust.
Okay, also AktivistInnen, Verbände, mehr auf Japan und zugehen. Und alle Einzelpersonen, nächstes Jahr ist in Deutschland Wahlkampf.
Wenn ich da noch kurz einhaken, es gibt ja auch einfach nicht so viele. Aber natürlich können auch, wenn ich weiß, ich wohne irgendwo, das ist der Wahlkreis von Abgeordneten XY, kann ich mich ja auch mit ein paar Leuten zusammentun und sagen, wir sind hier interessierte BürgerInnen aus ihrem Wahlkreis. Und deswegen wollen wir mit ihnen mal reden. Und ich würde sagen, im Moment ist vielleicht sogar gerade eine besonders gute Gelegenheit, weil ja kaum Gespräche vor Ort stattfinden. Man muss nicht extra hinfahren, das dauert nicht drei Stunden, sondern sag, haben sie mal eine halbe Stunde Zeit für einen Videocall. Das ist ja viel einfacher, im Terminkalender unterzubringen.
Ich habe jetzt ganz zum Abschluss noch eine letzte Frage. Ich muss es ganz ehrlich zugeben, ein bisschen persönlich gefärbt. Ich habe es am Anfang angekündigt. Mir geht dieses Thema auf den Sack, um es so deutlich zu sagen, weil es wirklich eins von den Dingen ist, die eigentlich, wenn man sie sich einmal ausführlich erklären lässt, ganz klar sind. Verschlüsselung aufweichen ist Quatsch. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt heute für diesen Tag Mühe und Not meine Motivation zusammenkratzen können, um das nochmal zu erklären. Ihr seid jetzt alle gestandene Profis in dem Ding. Wie zur Hölle schafft ihr das, das aufrechtzuerhalten, das noch mal zu machen? Vor allen Dingen, wie Markus es erklärt hat, in dem festen Wissen, das wird nicht das letzte Mal sein.
Ich glaube, man sollte über das Ganze erklären und immer wieder diskutieren, die Nachwuchsförderung nicht vergessen. Ich glaube, es ist ganz wichtig, dass die digitalen Organisationen, die wir in Deutschland so haben, auch viel für die Nachwuchsförderung tun und gucken, dass junge Hacker und Hexen nachwachsen, die sich engagieren für diese Themen. Ich glaube, in dem Bereich könnten wir auch noch mehr machen. Als wir diese Diskussion zum ersten Mal geführt haben, da waren wir alle noch jung und engagiert. Da hat uns das vielleicht auch noch mehr Spaß gemacht. Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, dass die Szene immer wieder frische Unterstützung bekommt. Das heißt, auch die Leute, die sich in Vereinen engagieren und einfach coole Events machen, Nachwuchsförderungen machen und dafür sorgen, dass Leute mitmachen wollen, sind genauso wichtig, wenn nicht wichtiger, als die Leute, die sich die ganze Zeit mit Politikern streiten.
Es ist wichtig, das immer wieder wiederholen zu können, weil wir viele neue Leute dabei haben. Wenn man sieht, wer war vor zehn Jahren im Bundestag und ist heute noch im Bundestag, oder wer war vor 20 Jahren im Bundestag, oder welche Aktivisten sind heute auf Mail-Listen, die es vor zehn Jahren noch nicht gewesen sind, dann muss man diese Sachen immer wieder neu kommunizieren. Wir hatten ja auch in den letzten Chaos Congressen diese Einführungstalks, die an Anfänger gerichtet waren oder an Neulinge. Ich finde es ganz wichtig, dass man diese Themen auch immer wieder aufbereitet, damit neue Leute einsteigen können. Und da gibt es auch eine ganze Reihe von neuen NGOs, die jetzt schöne Dinge machen. Es gibt in Berlin zum Beispiel diese NGO Digitale Freiheit, die ganz tolle Kampagne gemacht hat zum Thema Gesichtserkennung. Das sind alles Leute, die vor fünf Jahren noch nicht in dem Bereich aktiv waren und sind jetzt völlig neu dabei. Wir haben auch gleich eine NGO aus Stuttgart, die regelmäßig Politiker-Gespräche gemacht hat. Also es gibt durchaus auch NGOs, die regelmäßig auf Politiker zugehen und das irgendwie koordiniert. Ähnliches macht ja auch EDI regelmäßig. Die sagen über ihre Mitgliederverbände, Menschen auffordern, sich in Brüssel zu melden, per Telefon, per E-Mail, per Web-Formular irgendwo. Und ich finde diesen Community-Gedanken wichtig und den müssen wir auch weiter ausbauen, wenn wir die Netzszene in diesem Bereich noch stärken wollen. Jetzt auch gerade in Corona-Zeiten kann man halt sehr viele Dinge von zu Hause aus machen. Wir können keine Großdemos machen. Also müssen wir andere Wege finden, um auch unsere Themen zu transportieren.
Die Frage war ja, was ist das Motiv, das immer wieder zu machen?
Das Motiv ist mir klar. Wie hält man die Motivation hoch?
Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen pathetisch, aber Gerechtigkeitsbedürfnis, muss ich ehrlich mal sagen. Also wenn die Verschlüsselung kaputt ist, wenn die sichere Kommunikation noch viel weniger verfügbar und erreichbar ist, dann ist das ein Riesenproblem für total viele Leute, die von undifferenzierter Überwachung erwischt werden. Und da sind wir alle jetzt nicht unbedingt die, für die das das größte Problem ist. Wobei ich sagen muss, mich hat es davon auch schon mal ganz ordentlich erwischt. Das ist eine andere Geschichte, die einige vielleicht kennen. Das erwischt einen manchmal schneller als man denkt, aber gleichzeitig ist sichere Verschlüsselung, sichere Kommunikation für Leute, die in repressiveren Regimes leben, die unter viel schwierigen politischen Bedingungen leben. Und das rückt ja auch näher, Siehe Ungarn, Polen und so weiter. Kann das ein ganz riesengroßes Problem werden. Also sozusagen zu beobachten, wie Sicherheitsbehörden immer wieder auf allen Wegen versuchen, Überwachung auszubauen und Grundrechte abzubauen. Und zu verstehen, wie elementar überlebenswichtig es ist, dass es die gibt, international auch. Und das hat ja Auswirkungen, was hier passiert, dann auch auf den Rest der Welt. Blöde Formulierung, aber das sind schon Dinge, die mich da weiter sehr engagiert sein lassen und um die es einfach geht dabei.
Vielen Dank dafür. Vielen Dank euch allen dreien, dass ihr heute da wart und noch mal mit mir dieses Thema von vorne bis hinten durchgenommen habt. Es ist ein kleiner Trost für den Moderator, ich habe das grundsätzliche Thema schon oft behandelt, aber es ist immer eine andere Sendung gewesen, als ich wünschte. Ich müsste sie nicht mehr machen, aber vielleicht ist das ein kleiner Trost für mich. So, ihr da draußen habt es gehört, es ist ein wichtiges Thema. Es hilft nur, wenn man dran bleibt und man muss auch für Nachwuchs sorgen. Auch das ist ein Thema, das ist vielleicht immer so ein Intraschwerch dabei, aber vielleicht muss man das auch im Auge behalten. Also, Anne Roth, Julia Reda, Markus Drenger, vielen Dank euch, dass ihr heute hier wart. Liebes Publikum, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und der Spruch, den ich am Ende sage, ist heute wichtiger denn je. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.